SABBATINI.
DREW GRIFFIN SPOKE WITH
SABBATINI ABOUT HIS FARFETCHED
PROPOSALS.
>> Reporter: THE THREATS ARE OUT
IN THE OPEN.
>> I WILL MAKE SURE THESE
TYRANTS PAY THE PRICE.
>> Reporter: AND ONLINE.
GARLAND NEEDS TO BE
ASSASSINATED.
WAR.
THIS IS WAR.
GO BUY AMMO.
THE FBI SO CONCERNED DIRECTOR
CHRIS WRAY SENT OUT A MEMO TO
THE AGENCY REVIEWED BY CNN.
IT SAYS LET ME ALSO ASSURE YOU
THAT YOUR SAFETY AND SECURITY
ARE MY PRIMARY CONCERN RIGHT
NOW.
SECURITY DIVISION IS WORKING
ACROSS THE AGENCY, AS WE
CONTINUE TO STAY VIGILANT AND
ADJUST OUR SECURITY POSTURE
ACCORDINGLY.
>> VIOLENCE AGAINST LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT THE ANSWER NO
MATTER WHAT ANYBODY IS UPSET
ABOUT OR WHO THEY'RE UPSET WITH.
>> Reporter: IN FLORIDA --
>> HOW'S IT GOING.
>> Reporter: ULTRA MAGA
REPUBLICAN, FLORIDA STATE
REPRESENTATIVE ANTHONY SABBATINI
IS TRYING TO TAKE RIGHT-WING
OUTRAGE ONE STEP FURTHER.
>> IF IT WAS UP TO ME I WOULD
TOTALLY DEFUND THE FBI.
I'M ANTHONY SABBATINI.
>> Reporter: HE'S RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS IN FLORIDA'S 7th
DISTRICT AND HAS BEEN MAKING THE
ROUNDS ON FAR RIGHT MEDIA AFTER
WRITING A TWEET SAYING SEVER ALL
TIES WITH DOJ IMMEDIATELY.
AND ANY FBI AGENT CONDUCTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT FUNCTIONS OUTSIDE
THE PURVIEW OF OUR STATE --
>> SHOULD BE ARRESTED UPON
SIGHT.
COMMON SENSE.
>> BECAUSE?
>> WELL, BECAUSE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS UNLAWFUL.
IT'S TIME TO ACTUALLY START
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
FLORIDIANS UNDER THE TENTH
AMENDMENT AND PUSH BACK AGAINST
A LAWLESS FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> RIGHT NOW TODAY IN FLORIDA,
FBI AGENTS ARE CHASING DOWN BANK
ROBBERS.
>> OKAY, YEAH.
>> ORGANIZED CRIMINALS,
ATTACKING CYBER CRIME IN THIS
STATE.
>> GOTCHA.
>> HELPING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU DON'T SEE ANY VALUE IN
THAT?
>> IT'S A LONG CAL ARGUMENT.
THE FBI AT THIS POINT IS TOTALLY
USELESS.
WE NEED TO DEFUNDING IT AND LET
RED STATES --
>> YOU HAVE NO IDEA OF THE VALUE
OF THE FBI.
>> YES, I DO.
>> IS A FORMER PRESIDENT ABOVE
THE LAW NO MATTER WHAT?
>> THE FBI IS NOT ABOVE THE LAW.
>> IF I'M SAYING THEY FOLLOWED
THE LAW TO ENTER INTO THAT HOME,
SHOULD THAT NOT BE ALLOWED?
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS ABOVE
THE LAW?
>> HE'S A POLITICAL TARGET.
HE'S BEING HARASSED BY A ROGUE
LAWLESS AGENCY.
THEY SPIED ON HIM, THEY HAVE NO
RESPECT FOR HIM.
THEY HATE THE CONSERVATIVES,
THEY HATE THE REPUBLICANS.
>> WOULDN'T IT BE PRUDENT TO
WAIT AND SEE WHAT THE FACTS ARE
BEFORE SUCH A DRACONIAN
STATEMENT?
>> WE HAVE ENOUGH FACTS.
>> Reporter: IN FACT HE DOESN'T
HAVE THE FACTS BEHIND THE SEARCH
WARRANT.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES, YET
SO FAR IS REFUSING TO RELEASE
THEM.
MEANWHILE, FBI AGENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE NOW BEING FORCED TO
WATCH THEIR BACKS FOR DOING
THEIR JOBS.
>> DREW GRIFFIN JOINS US NOW.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S SOME LIKE
ULTRA RIGHT, THE MAGA FOLKS WHO
ARE CYNICAL AND KNOW WHAT HE --
YOU KNOW, I CAN'T TELL, DOES HE
KNOW WHAT HE'S SAYING IS ABSURD
OR DOES HE ACTUALLY BELIEVE IT?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, THAT'S A
QUESTION I ALWAYS ASK MYSELF
WHEN I MEET THESE PEOPLE, AND I
MEET THE ULTRA MAGA MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
THEY RAISE MONEY OFF OF THIS
STUFF.
THEY GET ON TV BECAUSE OF THIS
THEY GO ON THEIR VARIOUS
PODCASTS BECAUSE OF THIS STUFF.
AND YOU NEVER ARE QUITE SURE IF
THEY'RE JUST PANDERING TO THE
EMOTIONS OF A PUBLIC THAT WILL
VOTE FOR THEM AND SH